[Music]  if you're new to my channel welcome i'm  brian keating the chancellor's  distinguished professor of physics at uc  san diego i'm an experimental  cosmologist who builds telescopes and  takes them all around the world from the  south pole to chile to california and  even to far-flung places like outer  space today's announcement literally  shook up the world not only for  professional astronomers like me but for  amateurs lay people every curious human  being just like you the event horizon  telescope was constructed in the past 10  years and in 2019 made a stunning  announcement the first ever image of the  so-called event horizon of a black hole